la tête dans les étoiles gelé depuis que
je suis petit j'ai grandi au bord de
l'eau est au bord de l'eau je regardais
les étoiles je regardais les étoiles il
ya très très longtemps
nos ancêtres regarder le même ciel et
ils ont décidé d'avoir des idées
abstraites d'aligner ses étoiles
à l'époque on naviguait on naviguait
près des côtes
on pouvait pas s'éloigner de ses côtes
c'était dangereux qu'on vous savez plus
revenir et finalement on a signé les
étoiles on a découvert des nouveaux
continents ont découvert des nouvelles
choses
je veux faire en parallèle l'imagerie
médicale est à la médecine ce que le
télescope est aux astrophysiciens
je vais vous dire quelque chose
alors c'est un petit peu de la
philosophie ça vient pas de moi mais je
veux partager cette idée qui à mes yeux
est très très importante
c'est quelqu'un qui va visiter l'enfer
et regard de l'enfer alors il voit des
gens maigre qui ont très très fin très
très maigre et ils sont autour d'un
chaudron énorme gigantesque on peut pas
imaginer à quel point il est grand il y
à des millions de gens autour de ce
chaudron
il y à de la nourriture à l'intérieur de
la bonne nourriture mais comme il est
très grand il est très très profond ils
ont des cuillères on peut on peut
imaginer la longueur de ses cuillères
très très longue
et lorsqu'il ils sont fond du chaudron
et qu'ils essaient de remonter la
nourriture pour manger et bien cette
nourriture elles tombent ensuite le même
bonhomme va au paradis
il va visiter le paradis les gens
sentent en bonne santé
plutôt grassouillet il mange bien et
pourtant c'est le même chaudron la même
nourriture et les mêmes cuillère mais
quelle est la différence entre les deux
situations
la différence entre les deux situations
c'est qu'au paradis
les gens comme c'est un fait ils
nourrissent la personne qui est en face
à la personne qui est en face les
nounours et même si c'est très très
grand et si ça a l'air compliqué comme
ils travaillent tous ensemble
eh ben c'est le paradis cette
philosophie que j'aime beaucoup
veut dire que l'enfer et le paradis
existe au même endroit et que ça dépend
de nous pour le transformer je vais vous
dire deux choses auxquelles je crois
beaucoup
la première d'abord je suis acheté du
sud
je suis malgré moi malgré avais je veux
dire que je le veuille ou non dans mon
sang coule une mixité et cette mixité je
la connais depuis tout petit j'ai grandi
avec
pour moi la nationalité ça veut rien
dire
donc j'ai quelque chose qui est très
très important est ancré en moi cette
première croyance est la suivante il
existe une seule et unique nationalité
sur terre humain la deuxième croyances
il existe une seule discipline
scientifique cell la science qui les
réunit tout lorsqu'on regarde toutes les
disciplines et il en existe et je ne
pourrai pas vous les citer tellement il
y en a et en plus je connais
certainement pas tout
dans toutes ces disciplines pris une par
une
c'est bien c'est intéressant c'est sympa
mais c'est pas assez parce que essayez
de manger tout seul le savoir vu qu'il
est énorme
c'est très compliqué par contre si ces
disciplines se nourrissent entre elles
c'est une autre histoire
on peut imaginer une forme de paradis
comme ça alors mois pour sauver des vies
avant mais il fallait que je fasse mal
mon travail parce que j'étais dans
l'industrie militaire ne me jetez pas
les cailloux s'il vous plaît je me
planque
je faisais du combat management system
combat management system ça veut dire ce
que ça veut dire
dans une grande industrie militaire
française et un moment donné j'étais
dans un salon en salon de l'armement qui
a lieu tous les deux ans bourget à paris
alors je suis dans un beau salon il ya
des très beaux missiles des bons chars
ça moi je présente des systèmes
d'armement des sous marins nucléaires de
quatrième génération française et au
retour dans l'avion je me dis mais mon
fils était petit con temps-ci s'agrandir
qu'est ce que tu vas lui dire marchand
d'armes ou alors vous sais pas si vous
l'avez juste film et je vous conseille
de le voir lord of the war c'est un film
fantastique je me suis dit mon petit
faysal il est peut-être temps que tu
changes de deux directions
alors c'est pas évident de changer de
direction pas évident du tout et j'ai
décidé je me suis dit après tout entre
les sonars et l'imagerie médicale
un échographe géant il n'y a qu'un pas
et là je me suis dit quel est le
problème qu'il faudrait qu'on ait eu un
problème important en imagerie médicale
je vous ne verrez rapidement un patient
5 scanner 5 résultats différents publiés
dans les plus grandes revues d'imagerie
médicale internationale radiologie en
2010 par les professeurs coup d'essai
zaki impatience un scanner 5 résultats
différents il s'agit d'un problème dit
2d convolution alors là c'est bon je
vous ai perdu
alors qu'est ce que c'est qu'un problème
de des convolution un oeuf du jaune du
blanc je mélange je veux faire
l'opération inverse
ça c'est un problème de descons volution
arriver à faire l'opération inverse de
la déconvenue sion il n'existait pas de
standards de solutions sur cette
déconvenue sion les familles d'image
dont je vous parle c'est les familles
d'image les plus importantes utilisées
par tous les radiologues de la planète
pour le diagnostic et le suivi de tous
les cancers et aussi des accidents
vasculaires cérébraux
on a réussi cette standardisation
comment pas grâce à la discipline de
l'imagerie où est la discipline médicale
pas grâce à une autre discipline
mais grâce à à l'ensemble de beaucoup de
discipline
la géologie l'astrophysique écoutez bien
le suivi des trajectoires des missiles
balistiques
c'est sympa c'est sympa conçus et
utilisés dans ce contexte là et est donc
avec neuf nationalités différentes
avec une dizaine de disciplines
scientifiques différents on a réussi ce
pari de la standardisation de cette
famille d'image la plus importante pour
les accidents vasculaires cérébraux et
les cancers
moi je vais vous dire simplement
l'avenir de l'imagerie médicale
c'est un avenir qui est radieux parfois
pour découvrir des choses il faut de la
chance
pasteur que j'admire énormément disait
la chance sourit aux esprits préparés
je vais finir juste avec une chose
l'innovation toutes les sciences
elles sont humaines dépendance elle
dépend de l'amour de l'énergie que l'on
met dans son travail et de la façon dont
on va le faire partager
moi je suis sereine je suis le petit
vilain canard je suis le cancre du
village effet l'université de bab
el-oued
n'existe pas je grandis en algérie donc
si j'ai pas forcément des grandes études
derrière moi mais j'ai une foi une
passion que je transmets et c'est grâce
à mes collègues
son docteur en astrophysique docteur en
mathématiques
parfois ils n'ont pas le bac ils ont
fait 15 ans d'études en imagerie plein
de gens dix fois plus brillant que moi
c'est grâce à l'union de ses talents et
moi je suis juste l'état celle qui
allument leur la poudre mais c'était un
sel la poudre sans étincelle elle
s'allume pas et l'étincelle sont la
poudre elle sert à rien donc je vais
finir avec une phrase à propos de notre
avenir et de façon plus générale alors
c'est pas ma phrase c'est la phrase de
quelqu'un de célèbre abraham lincoln
l'avenir pour le prédire la meilleure
façon de prédire l'avenir est bien fait
de le créer merci